Welcome back.
We're now going to be in the
next section, section four in
our fourth test. And that's
problem one, 594.
Problem one.
x minus y is equal to 8.
y is equal to 3z.
And z is equal to 2.
What is x?
z is equal to 2, y is equal
to 3z, so y is equal to 6.
So x minus 6 is equal to
8, or x is equal to 14.
E.
I already said z
is equal to 2.
I sometimes forget
when I just said.
Maybe I'm aging.
Problem number two.
Todd is older than Marta,
but younger than Susan.
Let's say their first
letter is their age.
Say Todd is older than
Marta, so his age is
greater than Marta.
But he's also younger than
Susan, for his age is less
than Susan's age.
Oh I think I did this problem
inadvertantly.
If t, m, and s represent the
ages in years of Todd, Marta,
and Susan respectively, which
of the following is true?
And exactly what I
drew is choice A.
And this comes straight
from their statements.
I literally was just writing
this because I thought they
were going to ask something
harder.
But this they're saying Todd is
older than Marta, so t is
greater than m.
And Todd is younger than Susan,
so t is less than s, so
that's just choice A.
Problem number three.
If the areas of two regions are
equal, and the sum of the
areas of the regions is 5, what
is the average of the
areas of the two regions?
So area 1 equals area 2.
We know that.
And we also know that the
sum of the areas is 5.
So area 1 plus area
2 is equal to 5.
But then, of course, we know
that area 2 is the same
thing as area 1.
So we also know that area 1
times 2 is equal to 5, or that
each of the areas is 2.5.
And area 2 would also be 2.5.
We know that because they're
equal to each other, and when
you add them up it's 5.
So they're each going to
be half of that, so
they're each 2 and 1/2.
And they want to know, what is
the average of the areas in
the two regions?
Well they're the same
number, right?
So if you average two of the
same number, the average is
going to be that number.
You could add them and divide
by 2, but you're
going to get 2.5.
And if you look at the
choices, where's 2.5?
2.5 is the same thing as 2 and
1/2, which is the same thing
as 5/2, so it's choice D.
Next problem.
I'll switch colors.
Problem number four.
Let s be the set of all integers
that can be written
as n squared plus 1, where
n is a non zero integer.
N is greater than zero, and it
soon. is an integer, it is a
non zero integer.
Which of the following
integers is an s?
So n squared plus 1.
So let's get a feel
for what it is.
When n is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
When n is 1, n squared,
plus 1 is 2.
2 squared plus 1 is 5.
3 squared plus 1 is 10.
4 squared plus 1 is 17.
It's always going to be one more
than a perfect square.
25 plus 1 is 26.
There's 37, right?
So the choice is, it
has to be one more
than a perfect square.
So which of the following
integers is an s?
So choice A is 16.
16 is a perfect square, but
it's not one more than a
perfect square.
Similarly, choice B, 28.
28 minus 1 is 27, that's
not a perfect square.
35 minus 1 isn't a
perfect square.
39 minus 1 isn't a
And if you look at
choice E, 50.
50 minus 1 is 49, which is,
of course, 7 squared.
Actually we would have gotten
there if we had
just done one more.
7 squared plus 1, 49 plus
1, is equal to 50.
The important thing to realize
is that, the integers in s are
integers that are one more
than a perfect square.
So you just have to look at the
choices and say, which of
these is one more than
a perfect square?
Let's do problem number five.
So I have a circle here,
that's my circle.
And it has a triangle
inside the circle.
It looks something-- I try to
draw these as close to what
they drew in the book
as possible.
There's point like that, there's
point like that, and
then there's a triangle
that looks like that.
And they write this is the
center, of course, is o.
They're saying that this
right here is x.
They say that this
right here is y.
And then the question reads, in
the figure above, point o
is the center of the circle.
If x is equal to 40 degrees,
what is the value of y?
And you'll be like, how
do I figure this out?
I know the angles of a triangle
add up to 180, and
all that, but they've only
given me one angle.
And I don't know the angle.
Or so you think you don't
know this angle.
One of the things that should
immediately enter your mind
when you see this in the SAT is,
the sides of this triangle
are the radius of the circle.
It's the radius of the circle.
Because every time it gets to
the end point, and they
actually it draw like that.
So if this is the radius, we
know that this side is going
to be equal to this side.
Because both of these sides are
the length of the radius
of the circle.
And they do this a
lot in the SAT.
If something is a radius of a
circle, it never changes.
Anywhere you draw it.
The radius is constant as you
go around the circle.
So if this side is equal
to this side,
what do we know happens?
It's an isosceles triangle, and
the base angles are equal.
So this is y, we also
know that this is y.
Because they're the
base angles.
you They're corresponding angles
to these two sides.
They're the base angles
for this triangle.
Now we can solve it.
We could say, x, which is 40
degrees, plus y plus y is
equal to 180.
Or we could say 40 plus
2y is equal to 180.
2y is equal to 140.
Y is equal to 70 degrees.
And that is choice D.
Next problem.
Problem number 6.
A simple square is any integer
greater than 1 that has only
three positive integer
factors.
Itself, its square
root, and 1.
Which of the following
is a simple square?
It can only have three
factors, it
can't anything else.
So, for example, if we wrote
all of the perfect squares.
1, 4, 9, 16, 25, 36.
If we write the factors,
this factor only has 1.
This factor has 1, 2 and 1.
This has 1, 3 and 9.
I'm just writing out
all the factors.
1, 2, and 4.
So it would be 1, 2, 4, 8, 16.
I'm just doing this
as an example.
You shouldn't do this
on the SAT.
But I want to explain
what they're saying.
All of these numbers are
perfect squares.
But notice 16 has itself, 1, and
it has some extra factors.
While these numbers only have
its square root, and
themselves, and 1 as factors.
So these are simple squares.
So if we look at the choices,
choice A, 121.
121, I know 1 is a factor,
I know that's 11 squared.
I know it's 121.
And I think, other than that,
there's not any other factors.
It's not divisible by 3.
B is 100.
100's got a ton of factors.
I mean it's got 1,
10, and 100.
It also has 2 and 50.
It has 4 and 25, it has a ton
of factors other than its
square root, so it's
not choice B.
Choice C, 81, same thing.
It could be 1, 1 times 81,
it could be 9 times 9.
Or it could be 27 times 3,
and so forth and so on.
So it's not choice C.
I think A is our prime
contender.
Choice D, 64.
Once again, tons of factors
outside of its square root.
It has 1, 64, and 8.
But it also has 2 times 32.
It has 4 times 16, and
you could go on.
64 has a ton of factors.
And, finally, choice E.
33.
E doesn't work, because that's
not even a perfect sqaure.
What squared equals 33?
I don't know.
So that doesn't even work.
So it's definitely choice A.
Next problem.
Actually I only have 40 seconds
left, so I'll do it in
the next video.
See